à Glasgow.
- (tous): Now!
- Masie ne voulait pas
manqr r ce rendez-vous.
- (tous): Now!
- Saisir l'occasion dexxxxxxxxxx
dirigeants du monde entier,
sasasachant qu'ils sont
juste à côté.
"Les gouvernementsanananananant
et plus rapidement", dit-elle.
Ils sont des milliers,
comme Masie, à demander que
de la COP26, la grande mlelelels
climatiques, ne se conclut pas
par de simples prières.
"C'est la 26e conférence sur
lililimat et nous n'avons pas
encore vu d'actions concrètes",
lance-t-elle.
très peur pour son avenir.- I'm.
yeah, juste so scared.
- Frank, lui, c'est
pour son petit-fils
"C'est important, dit-il,
c'est la seule chance
qu'on dedededededededededededed"
Il veut léguer à son petit
homme une planète en santé.
(slogan)
Raphaël Savaria, un Québécois,
à la conférence.
RAPHAËL SAVARIA, Assoc. québ.
organismes de coop. internat.
- Vous voyez un peu la frénésie.
faire des actions concrètes.
- Pour lui, la lutte contr
les changements climatiques
est une question de justice;
- Les pays moins industrialisés
n'ont pas la chanclululululuer
la planète comme nous pour avoir
une économie qui est prospère,
et de financer aussi
cette transisssss
les autres pays, aussi.
- Il veut que son premier
comprenne que le temps
est co'i'i'i'i'il entende
la détresse des jeunes.
- Oui, je suis éco-anxieux.
la jeunesse est anxieuse
memememement.
- Les jeunes, qui se sentent
au bord du précipice,
par Greta Thunberg, j j j j jeu.
(acclamations)
"La COPcécécécécécécécécécécéc,
lance la Greta.
- Bla-bla-bla.
(acclamations)
- - This is shameful!
♪ Power to the young folk ♪
♪ Power to the yount t t t t t ♪
- "Le pouvoir à la jeunesse",
chante cet homme, car,,,,,,,,,,,
qui seront les décideursde demat
les choses en main.
Ici Elisa Serret, Rssssssssssss